So popping a level, what we can learn from
the example that I just gave you with page
fault service is in order to design a scalable
operating system service in a parallel operating system. You
have to think about what is the right recipe.
For every subsystem that you want to design, first
determine functionally what needs to be done for that
service. Now you've got parallel hardware and therefore the functional
part of that service can be executed in
parallel in the different processors that are available. That's,
that's the easy part but in order to
ensure concurrent execution of the service, you have to
minimize the shared data structures. Only if you
minimize the shared data structures will you really be
able to execute the functional part of that service
concurrently on the available processors. So, less sharing will
result in more scalable implementation of the service.
Now the problem is, it is easy to say
avoid sharing data structures, but it is hard
to practice. Because it is always not very clear
how in designing the subsystem, we can limit
the amount of sharing of shared data structures. Now
coming back to the example of the page fault
service, the page table data structure that the operating
system maintains on behalf of the process, it is
a logically shared data structure. But if you want
true concurrency for updating this data structure, it is
inappropriate to have a single data structure that represents a
page table for a process. Because if you have
a single data structure that represents a page table for
a process, in order to do the function of
page fault service, you have to lock the data structure.
That leads to a serial bottleneck. But at the
same time if we say, well, you know, let's
take this page table data structure and replicate it
on all the nodes of the multiprocessor, that probably
is not also a very good idea. Because then
the operating system has to worry about the consistency
of the shared data structure copies that are existing
on all the processors, and making them up to
date all the time and so on. So we can now quickly see what the dilemma is
of the operating system designer. So as an
operating system designer, we want the freedom to think
logically about shared data structures. But later, depending
on the usage of the data structure, we want
to replicate or partition the data structure so
that we can have less locking and more concurrency.
That's the real trick. The trick is, you
want to think logically. Yes, it's a shared
data structure, but based on the usage, we'll
replicate or partition the system data structures so
that you have more concurrency and less locking
for those shared data structures. So we'll keep
this recipe and the principles we talked about
in mind, and talk about one particular service,
namely the memory management subsystem, and how we can avoid serial
bottlenecks using the techniques that are proposed in one of the papers
that I've assigned you for reading, which is called the Tornado
System. The key property is less sharing leads to more scalable design.